[Music]
come out and play with me
and bring your dollars three
climb up my apple tree
shout down the rainbow slide down my
cellar door
we'll be jolly friends forevermore
there's ellen's song daddy will be home
soon home from work
did you have a good day
how are you
happy hot outside
guess what
marty turned over for the first time
today
carrie john and ezra
[Music]
this is the story of family
of man the father a woman the mother of
child the product of their union the
object of their love
family
man woman and child together growing
playing learning
milk to drink bread to eat
clothes to wear a warm house
songs to sing
books to read
these are a part of family
a part of one of the most pleasing and
difficult challenges under the sun
the challenge of setting up goals and
earning through hard work
hard play and careful planning what is
needed and what is wanted
the challenge of living in a changing
world
a world of machines and rising prices
a world demanding expensive education
for all
who are to have a chance
[Music]
this is the true story of three families
families talking about themselves their
lives their needs
their dreams
men women and children
trying to meet the challenge of family
under one roof
[Music]
mrs beatrice edwards delivered her first
child at age 16 her last child at 41
a quarter of a century of childbearing
altogether four sons and seven daughters
eleven living children
as far as i'm concerned about a big
family
it's nice to have providing if you can
provide for them
but in our case sometimes we felt like
we hadn't provided for them like we
should have on count of jobs
you know
if you have a good study income coming
in and can kind of meet your
responsibilities
there's not that word intention so much
responsibilities and worry
feelings which are well known to carl
and beatrice edwards as the mother and
father of 11 children
children who need a place to sleep and
need to be clothed and fed
about the biggest problem we have
outside of paying debt is
we have a food problem
we are not able to buy all the necessary
foods we supposed to buy for them
i found that powder milk works pretty
good
but i kind of use the canned milk to
make the cream it works out pretty good
when they are drinking we have some that
are drinking and some that won't
eleven children
needing to be clothed and fed
eleven children
needing to be cared for and wanting to
be loved
a heavy burden for carl and beatrice
edwards
a big job for any two people
[Music]
when they were small
the oldest one took care of the next one
and the next one took care of the next
one and it was also down the line
and then each child is different and you
don't know who's getting the most
affection
because one might feel like he's not
getting enough affection and other might
feel like it's not getting enough
affection and so it's just a little
toast in between there
then of course in our case i'm out
working and someone's taking care of my
children you see
my husband's not working so someone's
taking care of a child so that's just
where it goes
that's just the way it goes
not a lack of love
but so little time to spend with each
child
a love which must be shared among 11
children
leaving few hours in the day to give
each child the love and attention he
needs
so little time
for so many
[Music]
supporting 11 children means working day
and night carl edwards works days as a
janitor in the public school system
beatrice edwards works the night shift
in the housekeeping department of the
local hospital
11 pm to 8 30 a.m
laboring during the sleeping hours to
help clothe
feed and educate her children
[Music]
to my way of thinking
now every child is college material
and in our case i don't think we'd be
able to afford to send three or four to
college at one time
i tell them the best thing to do is get
a high school education
then go and take a business course for
themselves where they can go to work
clean and come back home clean
not like me
go to work clean and come home dirty
that's right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
beatrice edwards has come to recognize
the problems that go with the family
that grows too large
too fast
[Music]
keep them fat and barefooted yes sir
don't agree with it at all
although sometimes i think i was that
lady with so many of them
because at one time i had three
endowments at one time at one time
[Music]
it was some kind of birth control device
out but it's just one of those things
but if the birth control pill was out
and i do mean if it was out i would have
used it because it would have been no
more than taking aspirin i would put it
where i'll have to see it
and wouldn't forget it
i'm aware that the birth control pill
doesn't serve every woman the same
but you take the birth control pill and
if it doesn't agree with you your doctor
will stream that out for you
you put yourself on a good doctor you
know and he can advise you whether you
have one or two or three according to
your health
of course i was under some good doctors
too and they advised me too
but from 11 you see i didn't pay them no
attention when i should have
um
changed all night huh
i like what a family here i know did
they had two children
they got those children up to about the
ninth grade and then they started two
more children
where when those two children were out
of high school they still had those two
children in home
family plan is the answer
i should say about two or three that's
the limit and i don't mean to at one
time or three at one time either no sir
with young children still at home
beatrice edwards will have heavy
responsibilities for years to come
going about her life as she has but
looking ahead to the future when her own
children from first to last have made
their own places in the world
i don't have much outside activities i
go to church occasionally i do all my
visiting on the street
and as i say i like to go to rummage
sales and thrift shops
[Music]
i'm looking forward so i can travel even
if i have to travel with a cane
i want to fly
i want to ride on a boat or a ship or
whatever it is i like hospitals
i like hospital work
i want to be so where i don't have to do
the type of work i do now
i want to be so i can be sorted like a
great lady a volunteer worker
[Music]
[Music]
like beatrice edwards maggie johnson
became a mother for the first time at
age 16.
i got married when i was 16 and the baby
was born before i was 17.
i didn't want any i thought but my
husband he said that he would like to
have four i said all right four
but then when i got the fourth one it
looked like i couldn't stop
[Music]
at age 25 maggie johnson had given birth
to eight children
one child every year for eight years
it finally gets you down i think you
should wait at least two or two and a
half years
at least but i didn't and then finally
last i just started getting weaker and
weaker and i knew it was against me so
then the doctors they kept telling me i
was going a little
too fast for my age
so i thought it was time i'd better slow
down and then i had a miscarriage one of
the children's diet and then after that
i wasn't strong anymore
the mother should have time to get her
strength back and then i guess the
mother has to be healthy to have healthy
children
[Music]
with seven living children between the
ages of one and eight
maggie and ralph johnson together as man
and wife and with the advice of their
doctor
decided for both the mother's health and
the future welfare of an already large
family
that they would have no more children
one thing is everything is so high and
everything
and it takes so much to feed and close a
bunch of children now
you gotta have enough space for the boys
to have a room and the girls to have a
room
and then especially in the wintertime
when the weather's bad they're gonna
play and they've got to have some space
to play in
i want all of them to go to school to
finish school and as far in college as
they possibly can it's so important
there
[Music]
it's so important now
today at 31 her youngest child seven
maggie johnson works long and hard to
help support her school-aged children
by day a teacher's aid in the elementary
school where six of her sons and
daughters are enrolled in grades one
through seven
from 11 pm to 7 am each night a factory
worker
ralph johnson works from sunrise to
sunset in the shipping department of a
local furniture firm at night he too
is a factory laborer
[Music]
it takes so much
and i'm so sure if both of us didn't
worry that we couldn't make things meet
because with everything as high as it is
we just couldn't make it
i've always worried you know as the
babies get big enough i'd go back to
work
seven years have now passed since the
birth of their last child
and free time is still a dear thing for
the johnsons
yet during the last few years
since their decision to practice birth
control
maggie and ralph johnson have come to
know a greater enjoyment of their
relationship as man and wife
[Music]
really when you
got when you got a little baby it takes
up most of your time
they was also little like a little
hubble at one time one wasn't much
bigger than the other when we had the
little ones
we could never go anywhere
[Music]
when we was first married i just thought
i just couldn't stand him to use
anything
but i was sort of
get saw the ball up
i just every time i was just so sure and
i just didn't want to right then
and now when i feel like i'm not well
like i can relax better and it's a lot
different
i think when you feel that you ain't
going to get pregnant you have a
tendency
that's
a little different feeling there
because then before i just felt that
just every time i was
going to get pregnant which i did i
guess
and now when you feel that you're eating
i think you enjoy it a lot better
[Music]
do
[Music]
joan cannon age 29 is the mother of four
children aged nine
5 and 4 months
for joan and her husband jim a
construction worker supporting and
rearing two sons and two daughters
is a day-to-day matter
it's a matter of what we're going to eat
and so forth instead of thinking about
the future
every day is the same i usually get up
very early and we have breakfast and two
of the children go to school
and then i clean house and i wash
clothes and i cook
and our meals aren't very interesting
because we use a lot of foods like
dry beans
and that isn't bad but it involves more
work
we never consider things like tv dinners
because they're more expensive
i'm always very tired when the day is
over
i enjoy it i'm glad to see
because if i didn't it would be very
unfortunate
but i would like to have spare time for
myself
alone just to be bored
spare time for herself
time to enjoy her children
i don't have time to actually play with
them
and i think they would like that very
much
and i think it worries them some for me
to be so busy with the chores
continually
[Music]
well i don't have any rag dolls or
anything like that
but i have some dolls that i've had for
many years and i don't call them dolls i
call them children just like ezra calls
his bears
their names are marta greta and martha i
usually have them dressed but sometimes
i don't have clothes for them so they
have to stay in bed
but i always give them breakfast i'm
sure to do that
but most of the time they have clothes
because
my mother seems to think it a hobby to
iron
so
they don't have to stay in bed much
sometimes i bring them in the living
room and i take very good care of them
i feed them i take them to the hospital
if there's any emergency or injury
once marta the smallest and the youngest
one
swallowed a bottle of kerosene
so you can be sure that i had to hurry
her off to the hospital
and i don't even know what the doctors
did i was so upset
well i don't know what's going to happen
but maybe i'll be a good future mother
after all
i think it is very important to have
spare time it doesn't take very much to
make me happy
but if i can just visit a friend
occasionally it makes so much difference
it's very difficult to even think about
how i'd enjoy myself if i had the time
for joan
the responsibilities of the mother in
the home
for jim cannon as father the concerns of
supporting his wife and children
because of medical bills loss of work
and the day-to-day expenses of buying
food and clothes for four children
the cannon family has recently had a
hard time making ends meet
jim and joan
are concerned about the future of their
family
we've thought about limiting our family
off and on ever since we've been married
when we think about uh can we afford
another child
should we have one since martha the baby
was born i think both of us
now have made a definite decision not to
have more
because it would be an impossible
situation if we did
it's going to be a necessity from now on
things are pretty hectic right now and
even if we were to find ourselves better
off a little more stable well
the family is more or less complete now
with martha ann
families thinking back
looking ahead
aware of the responsibilities of the
world in which they are living
and the demands on their own lives as
father
mother
and child
under one roof
everything is so high and everything
and it takes so much to feed and close a
bunch of children now it's a matter of
what we're going to eat and so forth
a big family is nice to have providing
if you can provide for them
i want all of them to go to school to
finish school and as far in college as
they possibly can it's so important
there
so they can go to work clean and come
back home clean not like me
go to work clean and come home dirty
that's right the mother has to be
healthy to have healthy children
but i would like to have spare time for
myself
alone just to be bored
i'm looking forward so i can travel
but now when you feel that you eating i
think you enjoy it a lot better
family planning is the answer
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
foreign